make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so it occurred to me recently after
going through and and double-checking on
the videos that we've done that we never
finished flashy or one and this story's
been finished for a little while now
actually for I think about a week or so
about a couple weeks so we're gonna go
ahead and wrap this thing up
but again flashy er one is really kind
of a side story right it sort of deals
with Barry Allen like how he became the
flash and all that kind of good stuff
and what we learned up to this point was
that there was a guy by the name of
turtle of course we talked more about
him we went pretty in-depth into his
history what he was about
would you guys will find in in the
videos down in the description uh but
the idea behind this is that turtles
basically just a guy who can manipulate
the still force right he can slow down
objects around him basically take away
the speed from speedsters and it's kind
of a cool little little section here
swirlies is why I always considered him
to be more powerful than like the
reverse-flash right because of what uses
having all this speed if you can't do
anything with it but with turtle from
the future having shown up with Barry
Allen from the future what this does is
it leads to Barry Allen in the past
basically amping up and then going an
attacking turtle now this is a cool
thing about this is because a lot of
people might look at that and say well
this seems out of character for Barry
Allen and that's true
um when Barry first became the flash it
really depends on what era you're
reading right I mean Williamson's taking
a few liberties here if you go back and
you read like DC showcase number four
and and some of the subsequent stories
that came after Barry was very reserved
like when he became the flash he
approached it from a scientific
perspective
he wasn't just kind of like rushing in
and facing off against people now he did
to a degree insofar as he was learning
how to use his powers but it wasn't
really anything this this broad strokes
you know it was a really anything like
this this reckless or anything along
those lines and so because of that it's
really very coming to grips of the fact
that there are limitations to becoming
the flash and that's why this is so
important and that's why stories like
this are so cool is that just because
you have SuperSpeed does it mean that
that ability alone is going to be useful
against some foe right and with someone
like turtle it's essentially useless and
so what he does end up grabbing the old
version of himself and then to kind of
whisk away to to a sort of location
where they can just kind of reside and
recoup themselves and as a cool little
moment here because what the future
version of Barry says is that everything
would like all this will basically
happen right there's no real way for you
to defeat him now
the reality of that is that it's
technically true and that's one of the
questions that I was sort of wondering
here is how is Joshua williamson gonna
get around this right because what we're
doing is we're talking about a story
that takes place in the past with a
version of Barry that comes from the
future
right like none of this is taking place
in the present day and so because of
that ah you're essentially talking about
like manipulating time and with the way
it works in in DC Comics for the most
part time is a linear thing you can
invoke hyper time if you want to but it
doesn't really matter because the end
results that they all lead back to the
future time stream anyway so the idea
here is that no matter what happens
seemingly turtle will win and that's one
of the things that we were kind of left
to our own devices to figure out and and
really the story could have gone anyway
here what I mean all we had is a version
of turtle from the future who would
conquered central city and a version of
turtle in the past who's just becoming a
villain we didn't really know what
happened in between
but what older beery says is that this
is basically a paradox that what is up
happening here is that if Barry goes on
in like defeats turtle in the
traditional sense like destroys him or
kills him or something along those lines
then what it's gonna do is it's gonna
create a paradox
how could total come from the future if
he doesn't exist right if he was dead
before he ever got to that point in time
and that's why things get kind of crazy
or he kind of murky because Barry comes
to the realization that as far as his
future self is saying the only thing he
really can do is nothing and that's a
hard pill to swallow for Barry the way
that Williamson builds into this is by
invoking the old-school Barry Allen
storage right so again kind of
referencing DC showcase here the
motivation for Barry becoming a becoming
a hero after he got his powers as
opposed to just being a guy who goes
about his normal life and just uses them
as a means of convenience is is the
flash comics right it's one of the
things that DC hit on back in the day
that when Jay Garrick was the original
flash that in the universe that DC had
and in 1956 when DC showcased popped up
earth one that Jay Garrick was a flash
in a different universe so basically
Barry Allen grew up reading comics about
an alternate reality version of the
flash at the time he didn't really know
it was an alternate reality version it
wasn't until he went to earth to to that
ultra universe and found out ah but
reading the stories of Jay Garrick
inspired him to become a hero and that's
one of the reasons why in the old
stories when Barry crosses that
dimensional barrier when he travels to
earth to when he meets Jay Garrick for
the first time he says dude I had no
idea that you were real I was reading
stories about you but like I didn't know
they were based on anything realistic
you are my motivation for becoming a
hero
like you're the reason why I became a
superhero I became my universes version
of the flash in the first place this is
a very important thing here is a very
significant thing because what this does
is sets the stage for why Barry becomes
a hero I mean you look at the old school
stories and as well because it was the
right thing to do and I guess that works
to a degree but I like this more that's
one of these is why I like Williamson's
writing me
it takes why these heroes are doing what
they're doing and it makes them tangible
right it makes it it makes it realistic
and I enjoy that like I really really
dig that idea and that's why I bury
basically lashes out of course creating
his own ring with this with his flash
suit inside of it a hallmark of his
character it's really ties into how it
was that that was made but he tells his
future version I cannot just sit around
and do nothing
you know while Turtles using his power
in slowing Central City to a crawl I
cannot rest on my laurels and do
absolutely nothing while all this seems
to go to pot right like I have to do
something my job is to be a hero my jobs
to figure out a way to win even if that
that way is not readily available or
exceedingly obvious right when he shows
up and he starts fighting the future
version of turtle well then suddenly he
met he's met with us his you know the
past version of turtle as well he's
fighting two guys who can basically slow
him down who can who can instigate a
scenario whereby they can take his speed
away and Barry has to find a way to
basically face-off against the two of
them and find a way to win and that's
kind of the cool moment here because
what he does is he allows himself to be
taken over by turtle he allows his you
know turtle to basically take his powers
away but is it's really kind of a kind
of a bet kind of a gambit and because he
sort of harkens back to this moment with
his mom when she had this this little
bit of a discussion with him we don't
really get the whole the whole bit in it
but only really here is the section you
know this little this little point where
she tells her son you know you're always
hopeful and that's what Barry relies on
here Barry looks back at his whole life
right like losing his mom who is who is
killed by reverse-flash he looks at all
these different aspects of his life but
he keeps moving forward and always keeps
being a hero and that's really the
definition you know even when he didn't
have any powers he was always moving
forward always trying to find the best
version of himself and then once he
gained powers he was able to do that at
a much faster pace no pun intended here
but that's the cool thing is because
what he says is that the power of the
Speed Force what he channels is hope and
it's not possible for a turtle to take
only a part of that right he takes the
whole thing he gets the whole kit and
kaboodle and the speed that Barry
utilizes totally overpowers overpowers
turtle and Barry takes it back and
that's one of these cool things because
now there's a way around him there's a
way to get past him and that's a cool
moment here because Barry's not affected
by turtles abilities anymore more so
than that and this is one of the most
important things here whether the turtle
battle is kind of a cool thing and it's
kind of an aside it's really more of the
the small moments that make this story
significant when Barry Allen is you know
kind of experiences like this this
vision of sorts right you know this this
instance you know you told about the
multiverse and he sees what he calls
insane
images what he's seeing is alternate
reality versions of speedsters he's
seeing Wally West from from Kingdom Come
he's seeing like all these other these
other speedsters that are out there in
the multiverse and Maslin Barry begins
to realize that he's part of something
greater but here's the thing see this
this is what's kind of interesting about
this is the nature of the Speed Force
itself the Speed Force created in Mark
Waid you know created by Mark away in
the 1990s was just there it was just a
thing that was there as a way to explain
why speedsters can run super fast and
when Geoff Johns came along albeit
disagreeing with the nature of the Speed
Force what he established is that the
Speed Force itself didn't start growing
until Barry started running and then as
he ran the Speed Force grew more and
more and started to permeate all
throughout space and time and so because
of that the Speed Force is now
everywhere all throughout the entirety
of the multiverse and it's all because
of Barry Allen but he doesn't know that
yet he doesn't realize that's the case
yet as though it's a cool little moment
here because what he ends up doing is
actually using the power of the Speed
Force to manipulate time now this is
something new for Barry Allen and the
reason why is because Barry was never
really able to manipulate the time
stream outside of using the cosmic
treadmill but using the Speed Force what
he ends up doing is actually sitting
everybody in Central City forward by a
couple seconds and leaving turtles
stranded in the past and what it does is
it leaves him out of sync it's like
reverse time-travel under normal
circumstances we times for however we go
to the past or go to the present you
know or at least come up with characters
do anyway they jump to the past they
jump to the present what this is is this
really more of the world leaving him
behind and I'm sorry about the world
moving forward and turtle being stuck in
the past as opposed to turtle jumping
into the past right so it's a cool
little moment here and it's a cool way
to defeat him because what it does is it
kind of shifts things as sink or by
turtles not dead he's just timed this
place now the paradox I think still kind
of exists because if turtle was shifted
out of sync and it was done in such a
way to where he was never able to get
his hands on future Barry in the first
place and how could future Barry have
been here again it's a little bit of a
paradox here but what is up happening
here and this is really where Williamson
manages to make it work what he ends up
doing is actually moving up moving
turtle not really to the to the I guess
tank to the modern day or at least the
younger version of himself moving him
back to the present moment but then
throwing him in jail and so everything
basically kind of got reset to a degree
by Barry right I mean turtle was moved
to the past and then jump back to the
present after everybody was safe and
that was basically yet it's a cool
little way to end this story it's a
smart maneuver by Joshua Williamson I
think you know to kind of treat time
like a rubber band
sort of
snap back for a second and then go back
in place it works and I think it's
pretty effective but again like like
kind of a small little moment that he
ends this this year one on and this is
really gonna be great for people who are
flash fans is we get two things the
first is that Barry is introduced to the
nephews of iris right so he's introduced
to to Wallace West when he's really
really young
then he's introduced to Wally West where
he's a little bit older about the time
that Wally would become kid flash and so
as they kind of go through and they
start talking to each other and so on
suddenly they go into Barry's lab and
then Wally's struck by lightning and
doused with chemicals in the same way he
was in the old DC Comics and goes on to
become Kid Flash but we also get is this
great little moment where Barry's like
running with all these speedsters max
mercury Jay Garrick impulse all these
guys like all these features we've been
dying to see return and so I feel like
this is Joshua Williams his way of
basically saying all the speedsters are
gonna come back like everybody that you
know and love is gonna come back it's
just a matter of time and that's why
stories like this you know where they do
have their ups and downs they do have
their lulls occasionally they're always
worth following because the payoff
always makes you feel like you're a part
of a cohesive thing but I love it I
absolutely adore it but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explained to make sure you guys at the
sub button to become part of the rod for
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]